Hello,
we are back live.
Hi.
I am um quite tired today. Really quite
tired.
So,
I think all I'm going to do for this
evening is I'm going to try to get a
whole bunch of video clips of all these
environments
um and get them nicely put together so I
can start looking for
an editor for this trailer
realistically I can probably do that in
the next like hourish.
And uh there are a couple other
environments that haven't been fully
fully fixed yet. Maybe I cue a couple
experiments or whatever, but other than
that,
that's about it for today.
I gotta say it's way nicer at least
having a comfortable chair
evening when I'm tired like this instead
of just being like I don't want to go to
my office chair. I'm just going to do
whatever. It's at least I can just
relax a bit and do like this relatively
easy chunk of work.
How we're going to do it. Um
probably we take like this thing
files window.
Take care of this.
I'll keep these off on the side.
Start recording.
Congrats on the cool project. Any
suggestion or views on how to handle
standard deviation calculation for a
trading bot? Why is it everyone always
is trying to build a trading bot? You're
trying to speedrun losing all your
money.
We technically built a couple like small
things in finance. Um,
what do you mean the standard deviation?
Do you mean the risk risk profile or uh
like naive RL is going to do some crazy
things.
Oh, for the action distribution.
Yeah, the action distribution like the
standard
you're the word you're looking for I
think would be the entropy, right? If
it's discrete or I guess the I guess it
could be the standard deviation if it's
continuous. But that's just a learned
parameter of the neural network. Either
way
or like any environment, not just
trading
going to be I mean that you're looking
at like the entropy deviation something
like that.
This has quickly become one of my
favorite environments right here.
This is just like such a cool one.
Really
look at this thing.
Tetris Env is just awesome.
I like it a lot.
All for trading. Na I mean naively doing
RL for trading is laughable. Using it in
some capacity if you know what you're
doing isn't
you have to actually know what you're
doing. But
kind of magic that we just have all
these working, huh?
Took so long to get it to this point,
but it's pretty magic.
You can set the board size to be
whatever you want. It's just a matter of
getting it to actually learn
configurable.
it's not like we only implemented it for
small boards.
The main problem with Go is that uh it's
hard to write like a decent scripted bot
to play against. The action space is
very big and nobody knows the damn game.
Like you actually need to know what the
hell the game is in order to play like
to work on it.
Nobody knows how to play the game.
Well, it definitely can't beat the
current soda go models because those use
massive amounts of search. Um, but what
would be very interesting would be to
see if with like pure on policy RL you
could beat amateur players. That would
already be something pretty dang cool
cuz that I don't think has been done.
You're absolutely free to come try it.
We have the environment. We could use
somebody who actually knows the game to
look at it.
Give it a go.
Yeah, we definitely we get it to solve
the small boards. Uh it doesn't work so
well on the larger boards.
It might just be a matter of playing
with hyperparameters and invalid move
like invalid action penalties and stuff
like that though and rewards and
whatnot.
curriculum learning run 512 should be
sufficient.
What are you going to do with a stuck
puffer?
any reason
on GPU drive C network I should run into
any weird
weird LSTM stuff.
Not that I'm aware of.
I don't know. Just see if it trains. If
you just train it on that map, if it
does anything
That was kind of the idea, you know,
when I made it was that this was going
to happen. I didn't expect it to happen
this well so quickly, but
low render is just about fixed. What was
it, Bet?
Nothing's wrong with Blaster. I'm
getting clips, man.
Now, this is not going to be one of
those crazy things where you just you
have it fixed and you don't know how,
right?
Uh, yeah, I can chat about it. I'm
currently exporting some clips, but I
can chat.
It's covering it.
I need to wait for these to like get
more interesting.
M scriptton's rendering loop defines the
frame.
So there's just some weird compilation
difference I guess with mcript inton
being a piece of [ __ ] because like the
whole modern web browser is a piece of
[ __ ]
Hopefully we don't have to do this for
every end. just like band-aid patch the
ones that have weird issues.
In the meantime, how do you feel about
uh I bet for chess? How do I feel about
what dependencies for chess? Like say
maybe the local compile
imports uh like uh Absil CPP.
Absil,
it's a dependency. It's one of the
multiple
uh frameworks that chess needs to run.
I mean the important like if we get the
end and then I think slowly clean it up.
Um this is like a whole library
effectively. Well, this is moronic.
Chess should be like chess should be
like a few hundred lines, shouldn't it?
Because they they rolled they rolled
their own uh all their uh like header
files and stuff stuff. They like the
standard library ones were apparently
not good enough. So they they've custom
and not my fault they don't know how to
code.
Well, it's like Yeah, this is this was
really difficult. Has to be well
executed to like Yeah, but it's I don't
know. I don't know why it is I always
give you these projects that I think are
going to be pretty easy and they turn
out to be larger. You kind of get the
short end of the stick with a lot of
them. No, it's good. I need a challenge.
Time to level up. Yeah, that is also
true. But you got to also do it in a way
that's like gonna get you to a
reasonable full spot, not make a total
mess. That is true. The drone that uh
these a couple of undergrads submitted
earlier today was fantastic.
Yeah, that was very cool. They had the
GitHub. So, you know, I I was looking at
the GitHub. Yeah, it looked it looked
reasonable. Already merged in on the
like it's on the the beta build of the
site. All right, let let me just let me
just DM you this. Uh just so you know,
the shift pressing shift crashes it. So
this that's not No, hold on. I'll DM you
the the speed fix. We'll fix that first.
All right. All right. Shift is shift is
human control. So critical. Don't do
that. Yeah.
Ideally. Yeah. Well, we we won't.
Also, I think I don't know if Spencer
fixed it or not, but the whatever the
hell you did broke tower climb training.
Yeah, train training, you know, may may
or may not have worked. That was just a
fancy fancy looking render. You're
supposed to not break training in the
process. Did he fix it? Let me see. I
forget if he said that he did. If he
fixed it, that's wonderful.
[ __ ] I I already I already spent all
night all all morning and all all night
on that
an operate training again. Well,
so the thing is you can you could render
the you could render it the same because
I didn't change anything that matters,
right? It's just shiny here.
like like like
that's I changed the rendering function
only so it shouldn't not that's weird
something happened then. Well yeah we
have ants to discuss though. Yep. By all
means.
Yeah. So, um, basically what I've done
is I've simplified the ant simulator
pretty significantly
by, um, making the movements much wider.
So, um, I had this suspicion that the
action space was too wide where it was
like able to turn on a single degree um,
not have that much change. So, I made it
change turn 90 degrees every time it
turns. And that led to this behavior
where the reward function will spike
early on and then fall back down for
whatever reason. Um, and so I'm trying
to figure out how to prevent it from
falling back down or what's causing
that. I looked at uh the food
respawning. Um, so originally there was
no respawn for the food when they have
fully consumed a food source. And so I
think that was leading to like this late
crash in the training that I um have
since fixed. But now there's like this
spike behavior at the beginning that I'm
trying to figure out. Um
I can show you guys what I'm talking
about. Second.
Yeah. I'm also at the same time I'm
recording all the clips of all these
ends for uh for the release. The idea is
that we have like 25 of these. I'm gonna
get clips for all of them and then find
myself an editor. Yeah, just go ahead
and show me this the end whenever you
want.
Yeah. So, um I'll show you the latest
Neptune run.
And this spike has been happening
predictably whenever I do a training run
where the reward will spike up, the
score will spike up, and then it will
fall back down and then just kind of
stay down for the rest of the run. Yeah.
So that kind of implies that you get
some reward at the start just by acting
randomly and then the end dynamics
change or similar.
It's probably just that there's a bunch
of food around at the start and it is
not respawning in a reasonable way.
Yeah. So I've tried uh doing this step
where um let me have you rendered it?
Repo's open. I have. Yeah. So, there is
a minimum distance from the starter
colony for food to arrive. And I've done
a run where I literally just increase
that distance threefold. And the same
spike behavior is still visible. So, I
don't think it has anything to do with
the uh distance from the colony. This
used to be 100 here. Um
but basically um I changed the um turn
radius to pi over two. So uh only four
different directions it can go. And I
added an observation where um it has the
current direction normalized between
zero and one. Um so this will always be
one of these four values.
Um, and otherwise the these are the
same. So it still has the distance
squared from the ant to the colony uh as
well as the distance squared from the
ant to the food. Um, and I've changed uh
is in vision to always return true. So
um, their range of sight is essentially
infinite right now.
Is it playable? Does it change? Yeah.
Let's see. Can you play it and like get
food and that all works?
Yeah. So, I can This is them moving
randomly. Um, if I hit shift, they all
uh perform the way I've uh scripted them
to perform. You can see they're able to
get food, bring it back uh with no
issue. Um,
so this all works. This is with the um
movements
um sort of prescripted. That's like
That's like 300 ticks to like get the
food and bring it back.
Yeah. Uh yeah. So you're saying if I
were to leave it randomly, how many
ticks would it take for them to get
food? Like that's like a ridiculously
deep exploration problem at the moment.
Like 300 time steps is like a really
long credit assignment problem.
The time is not perceived continuously,
right? Like if you just make the frame
rate, if they move at the same speed in
real time, you just make it like a
thousand frames, like a thousand frames
for each of these movements or whatever,
you break all learning like pure
algorithmically because you need to get
reward signal in order for credit
assignment to occur. These ants are are
lost it looks like. Yeah, these they
don't pursue
randomly.
Oh, what about the trained? Yeah. So,
it's literally it takes them it's going
to take them like 10,000 ticks to get
anything.
Yeah. So, um it will take at least 300
for them or 100. What happens if you 10x
the speed their speed? Yeah. Yeah. So,
we can do that. Get a get a nightmare
scenario.
Um, man. You know what I did? Let's see.
I woke up on farm, found a cockroach,
even though there's literally no food in
here, and then I went for a run, nearly
stepped on a snapping turtle, nearly
stepped on a snake, came back, took a
shower, went to dry my uh to dry myself,
and I had like some big brown spider
jump off the towel onto the back of my
neck, and I had to like grab it off of
there. You [ __ ] thing. I was more I
was more pissed about the snake though.
Spider won't kill you. Oh, the snake.
There aren't no There are not deadly
snakes there. We have copperheads and
water moccasins. They will absolutely
kill you. Yeah, copperheads are [ __ ]
Yeah. And uh you're not getting to the
hospital in time around here. And they
probably don't have them. Is this is
this 10x speed? Did you recompile?
No. So, this is uh the eval uh this is
the most recent training run trained
after you change the I mean um so you
can see we've already gotten to like
2500 ticks and they haven't been able to
bring any food back. Yeah, because it's
freaking it's like it takes too many
ticks to do anything in this game. It's
extremely difficult for them to get to
food. Okay, so let's uh try think of
think of one tick equals 1 second.
That's like a better analogy for like
how the RL agent sees things. All right.
So you basically it takes five minutes
to do anything. And there's a there's a
there's like a there's a horizon too
with with respect to the the policy
seeing what's happened certain number of
steps ago. So
it doesn't just know the agent just
thinks so much faster than you that
after a few hundred frames, it's only
been a few a few seconds for you, but
it's been like several minutes to them
and they get bored.
Well, yeah, it's it's getting no not
much reward, right? Unless you're But
it's funner. It's more fun to say it the
sci-fi way that makes no sense. Well,
you know,
it gets it gets it gets bored. Sure.
That's
You sent me a command, Dan, to uh
rebuild. It's been a long time since I
ran it. So, it's uh build ocean. Search
for ocean. Oh, no. I have the build
ocean command. Um I'm looking for the
Python. Looking for the full compile.
Then you want uh it's going to be
puffer.
What's it going to be? Trying to I'm
trying to remember. No, let me pull it.
I gotta pull
pull my thing up. I have to be be in the
code. Um,
it's uh just uh my credit assignment for
Terra is 1020. It's pip. It's not pip.
It's a Python setup. What do you mean
your credit assignment is 1024, Spencer?
You gota be You're trolling if it is.
There you go. That one. I know. I know
it isn't because I set up the time the
time steps on that thing.
Yeah, that's not what credit credit
assignment not equal episode length.
That's not how that works.
Oh, uh question for how I can think
about this um as I'm I'm writing this
out. So, um, right now the ants, um,
find.
Yeah. So, I'm giving them a very simple
reward, which is just, um, one reward
for picking up food and a big reward of
50 for bringing it all the way back to
the car. That's the same thing as giving
them one for each. It's going to clip to
one anyways.
Okay. So the magnitude of reward isn't
that relevant. It is very relevant. It's
just that we we clip rewards between
negative one and one precisely to
prevent people from crashing learning by
doing that because if you give it 50,
you'll just break you'll break the RL
because you'll have massive gradients
and you'll just like nan everything.
Okay. Yeah, I see. So in the ants.py pi
I've got these um action spaces and
observation spaces. Um
the action spaces between or sorry
observation space is between zero and
one right. Um last time we mentioned
that uh if they have something that's
outside their range of sight we should
have the thing being given as minus one.
Will that be ignored or will it be
treated as zero or should I be changing
the lower bound here?
Should probably change the lower bound,
but I'll be surprised if that does
anything.
Okay. Yeah, this part where um if in
this case it's irrelevant because there
will always be food and there uh the
vision will always return true. But for
when there's limited vision, we were
going to set these observations to be
negative one. Um, fine.
So, would that be treated as zero in
here? Would that How would that uh No,
it probably just gets treated as
negative one. I don't think we actually
enforce the OBS bounds for um for puffer
ends, native ms. You're kind of going on
expert mode. We probably should, but
yeah, you should just change that bound
to be a negative oneative one to one.
Cool. And then um
let me think. Yes. Uh the other thing I
was thinking about was
um
the observation size. So um right now
it is eight different things. That's um
okay. If this uh changes, is that what
this shape corresponds to? Yes. is the
number of ops that you have per agent.
Okay. Yeah. And then for the things that
are being logged like score, is this the
average across all the agents for that
particular epoch or how can I interpret
these log except except that you you're
responsible for doing that manually? So
every time you add something to the logs
and you increment n like you're gonna
the thing it's just going to take
literally all it does is it takes
everything in log and then it divide
divides by that n.
You see?
So if you log at the end of every like
whenever an agent dies if you log your
score then you increment n by one then
it's going to be the average over agent
lifetimes.
If you just like wait 300 steps, right,
and then you log once everything at the
end of 300 steps, then it's going to be
the average, you know, the average
result over segments of 300 steps. It
depends on how you do it.
Basically, all we do, right, is we set
up the average for you.
So, yeah. So, in here, uh, when I have
the terminal condition, uh, and I'm
incrementing n, that's going to be the
way that this gets divided off. Yep. By
the way, there n equals one is saying
that this thing is averaging over one
sample only. You're probably like
reporting very very frequently or
something.
Yeah, it seems like the score has
dropped to zero and staying there for
some reason too. You recompile with the
um the with the increased speed. Yeah,
interesting.
I mean getting actual zero score. It's
like I you always got to check if
something went wrong with the end as
well.
The food is supposed to grow back,
right? It is. Yeah. So, as soon as food
uh gets there's like a hundred units of
food in one of those green circles. As
soon as one of the green circles
disappears, a new one appears somewhere
else on the map. Equally far from the
original colony. Well, I mean, see
what's happening. At least now stuff
should be faster.
Yeah, let me make sure that something's
been saved.
I mean, there are a number of different
ways that we do this. Um, like
technically the best way to do it is
uh we like smooth the frame rate or
whatever. So,
like basically it won't be running super
fast but it'll still be smooth. Um I
don't know like probably good to look at
for how we do that. Maybe ourware
ourware is a good example of that but
doesn't make a huge difference. It's
just going to render kind of fast as
well.
Yeah. So they're running very fast and
they're leaving pherommones behind very
fast.
Um, something looks wrong.
Why are there pherommones everywhere and
why are they evenly spaced?
Yeah, I'm wondering the same thing here.
Isn't it Is the movement continuous?
Um, yeah. So, the the movement is going
to be um continuous in one direction
until they turn. So, what is the action
space? It's like move and turn or
something. It's turn left and turn
right. By drop
uh by 90 degrees. Oh, well that's why
they they're on a grid. It's they can
only move on a grid.
Yeah, they um I'm more so thinking
wouldn't they uh turn at different
times? But they do seem to do that. Like
the grid isn't perfectly um gridlike.
Yeah, this is uh be getting any food at
all. No, this is looks like random
movement to me. Yeah, it looks like
random movement that's been accelerated.
But okay, I'm I'm curious. Um, what can
you tell me about um you mentioned
there's like too much in-game time
taking place between rewards, right?
Um so one of the solutions I had to that
was uh implementing a reward where um I
have like a small positive reward for
heading towards visible food. Um I was
doing like this as my reward for every
time step that the angle difference is
less than the turn angle. You can try
that type of a thing and like that can
work. It's better just to like the thing
is making them faster is equivalent to
uh applying like a frame skip. Another
common technique. Look, the problem here
is right like you have this temporal
hierarchy thing baked into you where you
don't experience time in plank seconds,
right? Like it you don't experience like
each frame as it comes like you
experience this time continuum where a
second feels like a relatively short
amount of time despite you actually
being able to uh see like you're being
able to process stuff substantially
faster than that. Um the agent on the
other hand doesn't have that. They get
this like these discrete time steps,
right? Where they kind of expect
something to happen and there to be
cause effect over that time frame. So
unless you want to get into fancier
architecture research, um that's kind of
just a thing you have to deal with. And
the easiest way to deal with that is to
try to make sure that at least simpler
environments have rewards that are
accessible within tens of steps. In more
complex ones, maybe it's within
hundreds, but then like then we start
doing more sophisticated stuff than
you're doing here to make that work.
Does that make sense? Yeah. Yeah. So
what if we reduced the minimum distance
to
and then back to something reasonable
size of a food source to something like
20, right? So then and also make them
move at a reasonable speed because I
think they're overshooting the food at
the moment. Like they just can't get to
it, right? Um I think
I mean you don't have to train this. You
just have to like Load it up in uh load
it up. See, and see if it looks at all
reasonable.
Yeah. Let me uh just build the ocean
here. Build the ocean.
Yes. Build the ocean to feed the puffer.
Yeah, this looks fairly reasonable. Um
they've gotten some rewards now for
picking up food.
Uh, another one has brought any back.
Oh, now they've brought some back.
Shouldn't. We're almost a thousand ticks
in. What do you think? Uh, is that too
long? I guess it's random.
This is random. This is just dot slants.
Oh, I mean that could be fine, right?
Like the You can It's worth probably
training that.
They shouldn't take long. I don't know
how fast your thing trains. I'd put the
foods right next to it, too. Takes about
15 minutes. It shouldn't take 15
minutes. Food's really close. These uh
this drone end trains in 30 seconds
here.
I saw Yeah, they said two minutes
earlier. Yeah. Well, then I changed We
can reduce that in any. So, there's like
config. Oh, wait. Hey, um doesn't this
look smooth now? Right. What's that? Let
me see that. Isn't this is this faster?
Or is it just smooth?
Oh, it's just smooth. It's not fast.
It's slow. It's super slow. It's like
it's underwater. Here, I'll show I can
make it smoother and rougher, too. But
we don't need to change those things. Uh
chest screwed up everything. So, I'm
just trying to make sure. Okay. Enduro
compiles normally here, too. Just making
sure that I didn't break the normal
compilation. Yeah, it's normal. Enduro.
The latest enduro policy jitters.
Yeah. Yeah.
like it moving back and forth is wiggly
or Yeah, we can smooth that out. It
would be nice just cuz it's kind of
awkward to watch. Honestly, the Tetris
and that uh Adrian submitted is like
really nice. Like just look at how
satisfying this thing is to watch.
Isn't that super
What? My kid's watching. He's like,
"What's this new game?"
Ah, yeah. Tetris is a classic.
Yeah, that's a cool one to do
reinforcement learning for. Yeah, this
is an RL policy right here. playing it
better than I am. It gets stuck
occasionally.
Good.
Okay. I got I got the resolution here.
You can see if see if it fixes the
drone. It'd be interesting.
Hopefully, it will not be uh this is I
fixed a different problem.
Upload as a file.
All right. I DM'd you the uh
the updated enduro.c.
I will check it out in a sec. I I can't
repro the enduro running slow problem.
Or is it Fireox? It's a Firefox issue
probably. Okay, I might have Firefox.
Holy, this is so cool. This is Look at
this.
I'm looking.
That's a crazy policy. What's up with
the rendering? I'm confused. Like, what
am I looking at? Wait, where why does
this thing not have my dozer?
I loaded in a different dozer. Did
Spencer delete my dozer?
The last ones he's shown have have not
had your dozer.
I reduce the number of time steps here
before I do run this training run?
Huh? Yeah. Do whatever.
Just see if you can get something. It
shouldn't take 15 minutes to It doesn't
do anything.
I'll see if that does anything.
Does it look funny? Like I don't know
what I'm looking at watching the uh
terraform
Making plots.
Like I like I know I know what it's
doing, but like just the the the depth
is confusing to my brain.
We will have to change the camera angle.
The amount of score and reward here is
much higher.
Okay. So we can we can basically see
then whether that is uh good.
I like this graph here.
I make the mistake sometimes of like
getting attached to how the graph is
forming at the beginning, you know, and
then it's these violent mood swings.
I mean, the envy you have should
honestly train in 30 seconds once you
get it right.
Yeah,
you really you kind of have to have
something that's relatively complicated
to not train in 30 seconds,
right?
Yeah. I mean, it does seem like it
should be a simple um
environment like I don't know it it is
there's probably something wrong with
the observations or
computation. Also, by the way, this is
we have super linear learning at 400
billion steps.
You see this? This curves like curves
upward.
Yes. Yes, it does. Yeah, that's not a
thing that happens. Yeah, usually it
just flattens out in like a log. Yes,
that's not a thing that happens.
So, uh I don't know. AGI achieved
internally, guys.
All right. Now, now we just have to
vaguely post on X about it. Yeah.
they just don't die, Jason. They just
don't die. Like this.
This is the part I really don't
understand. Why would it crash? Like,
why would the score start to be zero?
Well, it's either it's either the reward
or obs dynamics or whatever are wrong or
the learning rate or whatever the other
hypers are bad like it's any number of
reasons there
but like almost always with something
simple like it's almost always the data
though yeah exactly can you check can
you just check real quick if you like
does terminals and stuff done correctly
sure
want to do that yeah so is this on your
is this pushed to your GitHub
yeah let me push what I have right now
all
It's part of Bet's scientific training.
Yeah,
I like how I just I have work and I just
like we just give it to Bet as part of
his scientific training. That's good. I
want to I want to be useful.
It takes it's like
and it just it takes a lot to learn all
these things.
Yeah, like like anything it's going to
Yeah, this is pretty nuanced. There's a
lot of lot more nuance to this than
other things. So,
three weeks ago, is there a different
branch now? It's just main.
I'm sending you the the most recent. I
will I will await
There you are.
Inspect your GitHub
your GitHub commit history here. Impulse
Wars is so cool. This thing needs to not
be like impossible to build.
Yeah, that's the This is the thing. It's
like you can't just you can't just make
a cool thing and have it be hard to use.
Like you have to have it just like easy,
simple. And the bar on simplicity is
always higher than you think it is. Like
you say like, "Oh, there's still some
stuff that's hard to use with puffer."
No, no, no, no. You don't understand how
hard [ __ ] used to be. All right. And
it's still the bar is higher.
Um,
look looking on your GitHub. I'm not
seeing I'm not seeing the push. You
pushed it just now or Yes. Um, go to the
link I just sent you. I see. Follow full
follow link. All right.
Oh, this is a different GitHub. That's
why. Yeah. Wait for Spencer's policy.
Many policies
to see stuff.
What's there?
One I don't have is the neural MMO 3
clip
Yeah, I have one, two, three, four,
five. I've got 20 clips so far.
This is the time, folks, to get your
environments the puffer. Add them in the
release
that DM me.
Oh, you you have me the
not the entire file thankfully. Oh, I
just gave you the C file. There's
nothing nothing has changed at all in
the h
there are a number of all like there are
all sorts of projects around popper
honestly one of the other things is like
getting a better version of C library
but this is like
I don't just need people to do it right.
I need people to do it who aren't going
to make a mess of it.
Yes.
That's crucially right.
Well, we found a couple guys that can
actually do the uh math and physics
today without making a mess of it, which
was freaking awesome.
I really can't believe the quality of
that thing. That's like I don't think I
could find anyone at Stanford who that
honestly really. Yeah. I couldn't have
[ __ ] done that in my undergrad. They
they've had they've had some help
though. All the all the problems have
been solved by buffer lab that would
have Yeah. But the thing is the code is
still like right. Yeah. No, not nothing
to dis like sure they have our samples
and stuff but like look at this. This is
just like this is perfectly done.
There's like almost nothing I could
improve here. I found like a couple
small things where it's like not knowing
the RL enough where I made a couple
small improvements, but look at the
dynamics code here.
Hi, high high praise. Looks pretty
clean. This is just like clean, very
simple physics. Um,
and this is exactly what I want to see.
Like this type of stuff is so good.
This is like the type of thing that
would take me quite a while as well
because like it's always going to take
me 5x longer to do the math stuff unless
I like actually am in that mode for a
few weeks and get my intuitions back.
Yeah. This is really interesting. It's
like not entirely trivial math either.
It's like you don't usually learn stuff
this way because
you know like they won't teach it to you
in like in terms of quturnian. So you
have to take somewhat non-trivial
physics some sort of like four point
force model you have to convert it uh
into
forces that affect quturnians.
This is like I'm very happy with this. I
was like I kind of you know I started on
my own stuff like my own battle end
because I assumed that they weren't
going to do it nearly this well and I
was like oh yeah we'll make a drone and
then they just like completely nailed it
you put the print in a puffet also
has a max function.
Yeah, you had a lot of fun writing this,
didn't you?
This is why I tried to get you to do a
linear LSTM so you wouldn't have to do
this.
Two hours isn't bad. It's only bad when
you end up like debugging the [ __ ]
forever and you can't get it to work all
day.
Eightmeg's good. Good job.
Good job.
Also,
you removed the nice dozer for some
reason. I put the nice dozer back in.
I'm never escaping the Joseph can't
drive memes, can I? What? Joseph can't
drive things. I mean, look at this [ __ ]
How the [ __ ]
do you [ __ ] do this? Pull the stream
up here.
Oh. Oh, you're you're actually driving.
Well, it might be difficult controls on
on GPU drive. It's really fast, too.
Like, usually there's like normal cars
slow down a little. Like, oh, can we run
longer than just
or are you just crashing every time and
that's why it's terminating?
It's only like was it 9 seconds? Can you
can you break?
This is This is like This is like Yeah,
it's only like six seconds. Oh, there
you go. Nice. I crashed. Uh, so Joseph,
you don't need to know how to drive. Uh,
I was just, uh, test driving a Model Y.
It's totally you can just use full
self-driving. It'll it'll drive you.
That's kind of what I figured is it's
like if you're actually a new driver,
it's literally dumber. It's like
literally kind of dumb cuz like it's
just you're more likely to get into an
accident. Self learning. 100%. Yeah. So,
you'll be totally fine.
Are controls decent for you? Uh, it's t
the map is very hard because you're
merging. You're basically just merging
into a like one lane with another one
that's whizzing at you.
It's okay. I will be sure Joseph will
remember this. Any skill issues pointed
out.
Would there be any downside to removing
the punishment for dying?
And they die.
They die of old age after a long enough
time. Yeah. They have a certain lifime.
If there's nothing they can do to avoid
it, then shouldn't be punishing,
right? Okay.
Wait, I actually have to drive this to
get a cliff, don't I?
like like it starts out with you like
basically having having a crash. Uh
I'd say if it's 9, it doesn't even give
you n. It doesn't even give you a full
six seconds to like No, it gives you all
that's that's like two and a half
seconds it's giving you.
Trying to make it so it's more than two
and a half seconds.
You can't just watch the train policy in
in first person.
Nice.
You have to hold cell.
Thing is, doesn't it do it? Like if I
just take my
It literally does it. Like I can't do
it, but it does it. Yeah, it should be
doing it right because it's a train
policy. Yeah, but I can't even do it
like trying to get it like several times
in a row.
Well, it's really it's really hard. Uh,
there it is.
Uh, it's two taps.
So, so now now you're now now you're
just you're just memorizing the
determinism there. You're not you're not
actually playing
It looks kind of jank though, Spencer.
The the wibble
that could be smoothed out like with
just rendering.
Does one of these log things appear only
when an ant dies? Is that the right way
to think about that? They appear on
terminals.
I'm assuming it's when you're calling ad
log. I just finishing looking at the
code.
the LSTM in the back end. Is that like
long short-term memory machine? Is that
uh with the forget gate and stuff?
Long short-term memory. It's got a
couple It's got a couple more gates and
it's machine. There's no machine in it,
but yes. Yeah.
What do you mean by no machine?
Not what it's called. It's state
machine. Yeah, it's not it's not like
it's not like that. It's it's like a
neural network type.
It's called um
it's called long-term memory. The M is
memory.
I see.
What is
I got this clip for Terra?
We need on the website stuff. I got a
clip.
It is the environment of all
environments.
Proof of that is I currently have a run
that is trained for
over 8,000 years worth of game
been running. That's pretty cool.
I have a new website one for you. Okay,
send it over
You sent it to me, right? Yeah, you did.
Fix that real quick.
How much is How many obs is it supposed
to be?
How many what? Sorry. What's your
observation size?
Should be eight. 0 through seven.
I don't have the new Dozer model. Do
you?
Yeah, I have the new Dozer. I just
haven't committed it. I'll commit him.
I need the uh the weights file though of
whatever you trained slash whatever else
you want to commit.
because you have you have obsidocate
antsm
function. I do in yourh. Yeah, that's
old. Then where where is it? Allocate
ants_m
in the ants.h file. Now I'll wait to
send it to you with latest.
Wait, what? What do you want me to do,
Spencer?
Yeah, that needs to be fixed. Cuz I want
I want to put the new model on the
website,
right?
Wait for me to PR before you. Oh, okay.
But is it trained? Five minutes. Cool. I
can wait five minutes.
We can wait. I'm attempting a training
run with the fixed observation size
right now.
Check this out.
Run here.
Got BPU is pretty nicely loaded.
Up time 2 days 6 hours.
The thing has been training for 54
hours.
over 300 GPU hours.
Each GPU hour, it trains a billion
steps.
A billion steps is about 20 years worth
of games.
That means that on one box every hour it
plays 120 years. What's that? 6,000
years total then, right?
I don't know. I might have miscounted a
little bit. That's like napkin math, so
it's within the within the range.
Should I think it's eight, but I don't
know
because I think it plays a little bit
more than a billion an hour, right?
Yeah, it plays like one and a half
billion an hour. like 30 years.
So m you're your log strct.
Do you do you look at the or look at the
order that you're declaring the
log strct
float uh n I see this comment episode
return episode length n reward
um it says n is required as last field.
Yeah, Joseph, does that order matter
that you declare them in? N is required
as last field.
So, you need to switch your reward and
your N. Yep. Fixing that right now. It
says it right in the right in the
template, doesn't it? Does say it. I I
did reference the doc. I just wanted to
uh says it right in the damn template.
I referenced the doc. I can only look I
would love to make it so that you it's
impossible to make these classes of
mistakes but I can only do so much.
Understandable. Yeah, I should have read
the comment. I mean it's a kind of like
on one hand it is kind of a dumb thing
to have required but I don't know how
else to do it because it's C. But I can
only read the bites out of your strct.
It has to be I'd have to make it the
first or the last or you'd have to tell
me. What you'll be doing is you'll be
reading the you'll be reading the uh
reward
uh bytes instead of the n bytes
if if you declare them in the in a
different order.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, so I've fixed that and the
observation size says eight at the
bottom. Um, the only other thing would
be if you want come up with a more
creative way to do terminals simply
because your ant lifetime is either
you're killing ants unnecessarily.
Sorry, I have a baby in here crying.
um you're killing ants unnecessarily to
make their lives end quickly so that you
can actually do uh logging or you need
to come up with a better terminal so
that you can uh
actually have have logs.
Um when the ants die
um
that's just right. That's the only
terminal condition though, right? There
isn't a different one. That's right. So
it's, you know, it's not happening very
often
probably. Well, almost certainly.
I mean, it's it happens like every
couple thousand ticks at least. Um like
it doesn't doesn't necessarily have to
but uh
if you want to get the logs more
regularly that is uh
come up with a better a better terminal
scenario. You could pick basically
anything. It doesn't have to be
an ant dying. You could pick a terminal
like just uh when an ant gets a food and
brings it back. Like that could be a
terminal condition.
It's gonna be what episode gets a goes
out goes out brings the food back.
That's that's episode
I suppose. I mean it's just the question
of log frequency though, right? It's not
going to change anything about the
learning. I don't think it will change
anything about the learning or it ought
not to. Is that's right, Joseph?
log log the terminal frequency that is
how how often the terminal condition
triggers
should not uh if it's not changing like
the reset or anything then no if
changing the way stats are reported can
change perception of things perception
but not the actual learning itself
okay policy on 512 verse 1024 isn't
working.
You probably tuned the learning rate for
1024 now.
Eval work. C policy don't.
Oh, eval work. C policy don't. Then you
must have forgotten to like
network size one of the hidden layer
dimensions,
right?
You know how hard I've stared at all
this code?
Let me tell you, I've stared at a lot of
code.
And that size. Okay, that just
Is there anything else you're seeing?
Dan, this is it. Um,
yeah, we already got allocated ads and
we already got the reward uh the log
structure reward end flipped. Uh, other
other than that, no, it looks like it
should be fine. Uh,
Um, that game like totally flopped. It
took forever and he didn't do anything.
We're like four minutes into the
training run and the Neptune doesn't
look uh that different.
Probably not different than
checking your actual like map and
functions and stuff. Like I'm not I'm
only looking for consistency with the
puffer lib. uh
scheme.
So
yeah, so I've checked the um math since
I'm using the same helper functions in
my C file. And so if the helper
functions didn't work, then when I
pressed shift, they wouldn't be able to
go to find the food properly. Like
the jukes, dude.
This thing is Are you watching your
policy?
This thing it's like it plays slow, but
like this would be okay. I actually The
thing is that since this is based on
Runescape mechanics and this is the only
game I was ever like a top 1% player in,
um like it's doing t it's doing tick
pathing.
So, perfect tick pathing is like
it's like an endgame MMO player
mechanic. It's basically the game is
like under the hood, it is everything is
done in terms of tiles. It is perfectly
like essentially by the time something
is in range to hit it, it's out of range
like perfectly. It's like a discretized
kiting thing. It just last hit that gun.
I think did it last hit. You get the you
get the kill credit if you get last. It
just it just swung by and took the kill.
It looked like
it's just doing professions and and and
then it goes and does the uh battling
every so often. The like right there. It
knows that that's going to it's going to
get one hit by that.
It's like look at the jukes on this
thing.
Yeah. Uh, it doesn't know how to kite
this thing, though. It or it didn't
bother kiting.
Oh. Oh. All right.
Boom. Boom. A tough. Is that a tough
one? Level 14.
Oh, 14 versus level
five.
I don't know why it does. It's weird
that it lets itself take hits.
Yeah,
maybe it has to in order to That was
market.
It used the market. It's buying [ __ ]
It's trying to buy [ __ ] I hear buying
[ __ ] in combat.
Is it Wait, is it going to try to buy
It's probably seeing if anybody is
trying to sell a weapon. It's going to
It's going to get a good wants like a
sword. It probably wants a sword. Oh, it
doesn't have a sword right now. A bow.
It doesn't know how to kite with the bow
yet, though. That would be the tech.
Oh. Oh, okay. I I see. Okay. It's
actually shooting a a bow.
just chilling. Yeah, I'm looking forward
to when the ants have like a division of
labor and they're soldier ants fighting
each other. Yeah,
having combat makes it get them training
first otherwise they they'll never
they'll never fight. Yes, unfortunately.
Got to get teach them how to get food
first.
build up their muscles before. So, you
should you should go over your go over
your functions, make sure they're
actually functioning how you think they
they do because
nine times out of 10, it's that that
blocked in, but they're kind of just
chilling. Yeah, they're friends. They're
allies. Oh, wait. That one's level two,
though. He should be able to hack his
way out. Now they can't fight each
other.
Are they Are they Are they friendlies?
Yeah, there's no PvP enabled.
Oh, okay. I see. These are other
players. They're not the uh NPC enemies.
I mean, this is like crazy to watch
because this is
so like mechanically these things are
super human.
So, so if you have a really, really,
really strong
player, you could just block them in
with with your other guys and that would
stop them, wouldn't it? Yeah, you can
totally get blocked in. I got to see
Spencer's PR, but
I mean, this is so freaking crazy. Did
you check the uh check to see if the
drone speed thing can be fixed? I
haven't yet. The the thing these are
lacking intentionality is the only
thing. Like they're kind of happy just
chilling until like there happen to be
enemies. They don't like go try to find
them, you know? Shouldn't it be actively
doing professions?
Uh so it right now it's at level eight.
It can't get any higher level until it
defeats a high enough level enemy to get
the next tier of harvesting equipment.
So nothing that it harvests right now
will help it. I get this thing from
Spencer.
Let's go see Spencer's PR.
See what have you brought to ZA
I always comment all this like
precomplete stuff
but I will take
that 20 27 megabyte. Hello Metro. It's a
big big Wait, why is it me? It's Mero. I
always read it as Hyper Metro. I don't
know why.
Welcome
this stream.
Bulldozer policy. It gets stuck too
easily. You see
good policy.
It dozes.
Doesn't doze as much as the other dose
in policy, but it dozes.
See this? This is tele. This is like it
relying on teleportitis cuz it can get
stuck.
It's decent.
I did fix this shader thing.
Something's about right.
I think I screwed stuff up with some of
the stashes.
The heck happened
wrong with our dozer?
Wrong with dozer?
Yeah.
makes sense because I'm I'm looking
through the um C file and every function
that I use that interacts with the
environment is also used in here.
And if they didn't have the angle right,
they wouldn't be able to point
themselves towards food properly. And if
they didn't get the distance right, they
wouldn't be able to uh decide which is
the nearest source of food accurately.
So angle and distance are both correct.
What's up? Um,
which is most of
Yeah, what up? I'm just trying to figure
out why the shader isn't working when it
working before.
I don't know. Did I break everything? I
don't know if I did a bad merge or what.
Dude, I'm tired. Um, let me get a let me
get a beer. I'll finish this stuff.
That's That's big old have all these.
I'll have to find the I'll have to find
the editor tomorrow, but I have I did
get all the clips today. See this? All
the clips.
Thanks. Good beer.
I need to figure out what I'm going to
eat for dinner now. Not alcoholic, to be
clear.
Best part about non-alcoholic beers is
you can have them for breakfast if you
want.
I can have beer and it's not bad for me.
Is it a high calorie or is it like not
high calorie? Well, 70 calories, but
also um calories aren't exactly a
problem for me. So,
that the last thing that you needed for
me on uh environments? Joseph,
you can go yell at Captain to fix his
impulse wars so it doesn't look like
this.
Does it look bad?
got this jank mcripton thing on it and
the stuff doesn't load and all sorts of
things. It's rendering funny.
Doesn't load the shaders. All sorts of
things. Oh, this driving thumbnail is
really cool. That has something to do
with the uh
compilation, doesn't it?
I I think it's going to be start
thinking about drone things. Um drone
things and terraform things. Make a
drone of or a drone drone racing.
I think that those guys could do it very
easily. Like it would just be add rings.
Do they have a drone like IRL? If they
need one, I can send them one. I have a
drone.
I feel like they could do the drone
racing thing pretty easily.
I mean, if you look at the code, it's
like very very nice.
I want to look at it tomorrow. The [ __ ]
is wrong? Why burying frag position
does not mech make Oh, you know what
probably happened
like
local compile does not look like look
look like that, right?
Hang on.
terraformer.
That was a
there first person on this. No, I didn't
make a first person on this. It would be
even more chaotic than the GPU drive one
considering how fast it runs around.
Yeah. Zips around. See, Matan, this is
uh I made it zippy so that it actually
works. And if we want it to like run, if
we want to just run it at a reasonable
weight rate, we just slow it down.
Yeah, makes sense. Way easier. And look
at this thing. This thing terraforms.
We're shipping it out to Mars next week.
Yeah. Yeah. XAI is going to need help.
All the help they can get.
Yeah. We're just going to ship it
straight to Mars. No, actually XAI is
hiring.
I still think it's way less efficient
than just like an AC path algorithm, but
that'll be the baseline, I guess,
eventually. I mean, it's it's an initial
like it's a prototype and the thing is
it's also reactive
potentially.
Yeah, potentially.
I mean, I feel like it did a pretty
decent job. I mean, 91% is pretty solid.
I mean, that's just saying there's a
little bit of dirt in different places
that are not fully in the right spot. I
mean, in reality, there's tolerances in
the field of moving dirt. I wonder if we
have actual data, the actual operator,
how
How much do they train to what
percentage?
Um well in in real um dirt works what
you first do is you actually only do
like say like 70 80% of it which is
called a rough grade and then you like
have to wait for like other things to
happen and then eventually you'll do a
final grade on top of it and then that's
like everything being as close to
perfect or within the range of
reasonleness.
Because because we we could also have a
robot like a lot of these things. We
could have a robot and actually run the
code on the robot and have it actually
do stuff like in a sandbox or whatever.
that it's compare remote control
operator to uh RL powered
robot. Yeah. I mean, and that's like a
super jerryrigged policy to make that
work. Well, sure. You know, it's just
basically a demo, right? Yeah.
But I'm talking longer term. That was uh
my first attempt at uh curriculum
learning.
That was
of the smallest degree. Yeah. Because
the terraforming problem becomes harder
as you solve it. Um because more dirt is
in the right place and dirt you need to
grab from is in potentially further away
places. That makes sense. Um so you have
to explore more to get probably less
reward.
But did you didn't use curriculum
learning though, did you?
Um, I did one task that got it up to
like 60% and then I created a different
task where it was trying to basically
only solve maps that start at 70%
complete and above and then train that
on the same split the starting point of
the previous model and then eval it from
0% to now it gets 91%.
After you after you grafted on the uh or
after you divided it divided it into two
curricula. Yeah. Cool.
Very cool.
Then yeah, do a third one.
Third theoretically that I I could do a
third one. I was just trying to get this
done. Yeah, makes sense. Very cool.
Tired.
But I'm certain that uh who's the person
in here that's between ants? Maton. I'm
certain that M and I are going to run
into very similar issues if we if uh we
end up doing multiple dozers because
like
it's a similar issue where if you want
to get things to cooperate, you have to
kind of do a bunch of other stuff
or you know just reward it, right? You
have to tune the
Yeah, I'm thinking if we want them to um
in the case of the ants emerge the
collaborative use of pherommones
um I think they it's something that they
need to naturally figure out for
themselves. So I feel like hard coding
reward functions to get them to
collaborate is one thing. Um, but if you
can kind of make the reward function
general enough, they can start to just
realize like, hey, we can work faster if
we do it this way. And if they're all on
the same policy, then there's no reason
for them not to emerge that kind of
behavior.
I do think a general reward structure
can work. It just makes it you have to
train it, I think, for like way way way
way longer because I ran into things
when I was doing this with dozers when I
was doing multiple on on the demo. was
doing single so I could easily solve
because I gave up a multiple for the
time being. Um because he was doing
things where they were competing with
each other for resources
and then also in the environment before
I was like splitting them up into
quadrants for them to solve and then say
there's two neighboring quadrants they
would steal each other's dirt as well.
Interesting. And so I would create like
penalties to do like so like don't like
screw up with things that are done.
don't like take things from your
neighbors and stuff like that. And that
actually that worked. Um,
but it didn't necessarily make them
cooperate. It just made them like not
try to ruin each other like
independently solve.
Yeah, that's interesting. It's like a
mini society. You got to enforce
punishments when it comes to bad
behavior.
But I do think you could probably get
away with it without any penalties on
that degree.
um if you did like a proper shared
reward and maybe some degree of like
independent
two um team rewards that you would kneel
over.
So were these uh dozers on different
teams in some way in the policy? Um, no.
I guess what I mean by is like in the
beginning you focus on the individual
rewards so that it can like learn the
mechanics of what it's even doing and
then over time you weight them less and
then you weight the team rewards higher.
Yeah,
because in the end of the day the whole
thing is one team. Like in in this
problem there's not multiple teams. Is
it just like as many dozers on the map
working together
to get the map to to get it like 100%
from original dirt, whatever your
original topology is um to your target.
Yeah. I mean, I think um you're probably
right that we're going to run into
similar things. Like I'm still on the
part of trying to get them to even
figure out the mechanics of what they're
doing.
But I think
once it's there, it should be an
interesting problem to see um how to get
them to collaborate or what their
propensity is or is not to collaborate
given the reports.
Um, I wonder if there's some kind of
function that you can show like um you
define certain um non-colaborative or
collaborative behaviors
um in a way that's like easy to verify.
Um and then you
tune the reward function up one way or
another if there's some kind of
relationship between those variables
that you can show.
There's probably something in that in
that realm with what you just said that
works. Um I think it just comes down to
how you're going to define that. And I
think you just define it through your
reward structure though. Like what what
are the tasks that actually require
teamwork versus not?
Yeah. I mean I think also there's a way
to think about it in the in the case of
the ants. It's like pherommones, right?
We want them to use pherommones to
communicate with each other. So the more
highly weighted
the pheromone sense is to actual end
behaviors, the more they've learned to
use pherommones in a way that's actually
productive, right?
I guess it comes down to with that like
concept, right? Where you're using
pherommones
under the assumption that like ants
leave pherommones behind and therefore
another ant has to use it. Um,
how are you going to tie that together
though?
Like at the future state, you know what
I mean? Like say you get your food, but
like how are you going to tie that to
the fact that you did use the pheromone
of ant A or B? Are you just going to
have like a path? Are you going to like
constantly recalculate paths and if they
intersected or something? I'm looking
for something that's not just like paste
all the clips together. I'm looking to
see if I can find somebody that come
will come up with a creative way to like
convey what we've built using these
clips plus whatever else. And uh yeah,
I'm looking ideally to like convey what
we've built to a slightly wider
audience. I'm going to be paying
somebody. That'll be taking a lot of
work. The 30 second trailer, we'll pay a
few hundred bucks for it.
Like I could line them all up pretty
easily, but uh yeah, I can I mean I'm
looking for somebody who's done this
type of stuff and play them and um I
don't know what they charge for this. I
think it's probably like a few hundred
bucks.
It's it's worth it's worth it for sure
to to have someone I mean I like the
goal is that we get something something
that's going to get us like you know uh
like a thousand like you know 100k views
or whatever thousand likes like actually
have like a big post for the release.
I'm trying to like find basically like
if they can double the engagement that
we'd expect that's good value
for sure.
Yeah, for this release like this is the
one we want people to see.
All right, I'm going to head out and
grab food. Oh yeah, Spencer. Later. Nice
to meet you. Have a good one. Yeah. Good
to be my time. Oh, hey, Viper. That was
freaking fast. We have a we have a
graphic designer. Holy, that was super
fast. Hey, welcome. So, yeah, the
project I've got here, it's a short
trailer. It's like a 30 second thing.
Let me let me show you what we've built
here. So, we've got these like 20
environments. Some are games, some are
more industry adjacent. We've got like
this driving sim, but we've also got
like this uh this miniature MMO. We've
got like this MOA. We've got all these
arcade games. And uh we've built like
really really fast AI training for this
stuff and we're trying to find like a
cool way to convey this to uh a slightly
broader audience. So I have clips for
everything here. I've got all these
clips, but I'm looking to do something a
little more than just like cut them
together with quick transitions, right?
So yeah, I want to figure out like a
cool way that we can present that. So,
ideally like looking for somebody who's
done this type of thing, either done
like YouTube intros for people for like
longer videos or like, you know, kind of
has a a good way to like quickly convey
stuff like this, you know,
and pay whatever the reasonable whatever
reasonable market is for this stuff.
I'll look up like similar things.
Do you have links to any stuff you've
done?
Let me start putting these into a Google
Drive as well.
If you've got links to like stuff you've
done and about what you think you'd
charge for something like this, I'd be
uh very happy to get you started.
These are all like, you know, 10 second
clips or whatever for the most part.
Probably only using a second or two for
each. 25 bucks. Yeah, I'll pay you more
than that if it's good.
So, I mean, they're just games. It's
like they're clips of stuff like this.
Here, I'll show you. But the the import
the important part of it is not that not
that they're So, we've got like stuff
like this. We've got stuff like stuff
like this. We've got, you know, stuff
like uh there's more complex stuff as
well. stuff like this. But the important
thing here is like we've basically we've
made general purpose training for this
stuff a thousandx faster than it ever
was and so much easier. Like we have all
these games. They run super fast. We
train like these are all models that
we've trained on them and they train in
like seconds to minutes for the most
part on your local hardware. A few of
them take longer but it's like
ridiculously efficient. So this is like
a revolutionary research breakthrough
more than anything. And I want to convey
it to a slightly larger audience than
normal because like the vast majority of
my followers on X are like uh
reinforcement learning PhDs and
researchers and people like that. So I'm
trying to figure out how I can make it
like you know a little bit broader than
that.
Let me share the link to this.
Right. But the import the importance
Yeah. And I can also I can show you the
trailer that I did last time. So the the
one that I did for my previous release
uh was I mean I made it myself so it
wasn't very good. Right. So it's this
this is this is what I did for my
previous release. I kind of just cut
them all together
and then you'll see the little animation
I made at the end which I still have the
code for. Like I could include it but
I'm looking to do something more than
this.
It's the pinned post. Nice. So, how how
long did that take you to do? Just I can
make it better. That took me I mean that
took me a few hours because I don't edit
videos. Yeah. Yeah. So, just like keep
the a like the audience in mind is like
we're trying to get like more industry
people involved, you know. Um this is
all free stuff, but we do have a
business side to this and we're looking
for people in industry who are
interested in all the reinforcement
learning stuff we do.
[Music]
If you want to get people in industry
interested, you should do more
highlights of like other uses of
reinforcement learning. We're building
up to that.
Like we're building new like the the uh
Terraform sim for instance is
specifically to attempt to do stuff with
real hardware. Uh the drone sim is as
well. Like there there's several that
we're starting on. Um how do I let's see
share this
uh share
anyone.
Copy.
And I put this in there. That ought to
work for you.
30 seconds. Yep.
I can get you more stuff for this. Like
I don't know if it makes sense. Like I
like ideally there if you come up with
some cool ideas you can it you got it's
got to not be something that's going to
put off like you know industry people or
whatever. I don't want like some hip-hop
stuff or I don't want like it's also the
licensing of that stuff. There's a lot
like I'd be open let's say I'd be open
to it if we get something that's
tasteful. Um
but I think a lot of people just scroll
do stuff on X muted.
So here like let me see. So like I don't
know if we want to do something like
this. Look.
So literally this is how long it takes
to uh to train an AI to play Breakout. I
literally start this run and within the
30 second trailer it's already done.
Promote some links on it.
Um
here
I can yeah I can show you one sec. So
like literally this has been 23 seconds.
Okay. I've just trained this on my
desktop right here. And then
now I have an AI that can play Breakout
like perfectly.
But I don't know if there's something
cool we can do where like at the start
of it we start training it and we put it
up in the corner and then like by the
end like it's like hey look this is
trained during this is this AI video
editor this thing here.
No.
Do you want me to promote some links? So
yeah. So it's our stuff is at puffer.ai.
We don't have all the new environments
uploaded yet but you know we have all
the ones that I showed you from before.
Um, and then it's this is going to go on
my X and on my YouTube as well. So,
stuff will be under there and there.
So, yeah, like for context here, right,
I just trained this AI in under 30
seconds. This is something that would
take hours or like days before this. Um,
so we kind of want to get people excited
about the tech.
I'm a researcher. I work on this stuff
all the time. We work on this really
complicated technical stuff and it's
like I want to figure out a way to show
show more people this stuff, right?
And I don't know if I like I want to
make it clear as well that it's not just
games. Like AI has a very long history
of using games for stuff because they
tend to like they're actually really
good for developing the tech. But you
know, we have more than just games. Like
where's the sim we built?
Like we're actually we're starting to
have much more than just games on this.
if I can find the uh where did I put it.
There.
So, like in here there's also there's
this drone sim that I just got submitted
today. So, this is actually a simulator
of a drone. We have this terraforming
end which we're starting to use to like
think about how we can train
uh construction, how we can use
construction equipment to like terraform
an environment. The clip I sent you is
better. This is like a a weaker model
than the one I sent you, but that's like
a bulldozer sim. We've got this driving
sim. We're starting to think about like
autonomous driving stuff. Like there's a
lot we can do with this.
Yeah, I put the drive link in the chat.
I can put it in there again.
And then my DMs here are open on X. Um,
so just like message me here.
We'll get something going.
Uh, hang on. Let me get you the link
again.
I'll I'll see you guys later. Let me
know if there's anything further. You
can DM me or whatever. There you go.
There's link.
Yeah, let me let me let me DM it to you.
Hang on. I got to figure out how to DM
you because
uh where's
it? Literally hid your thing for some
reason. That's silly.
Message
they are.
That was funny. You literally got this
like instantly and hopped in stream like
to chat. That's awesome.
But I mean it's like it's it's like
several minutes of clips for like a 30
second trailer. So the idea is you can
pick out like a second here, a second
there. I mean probably like these
simpler environments are so simple that
you can probably put many of them in the
same frame. Um and like maybe the cooler
ones get full screened. I don't know.
It's like part most of what I'm doing
right is I'm looking for somebody to
come up with like a creative way to clip
this stuff together. Somebody who's had
like that creative experience because I
just haven't. I write code all day,
right? I'm a researcher.
You get a sense of the audience though,
right? It's like mostly professionals,
maybe hobbyists, right? But like I'm
trying to expand a bit around like the
formal researchers, like people in
industry who are sort of thinking about
AI and maybe looking for cool stuff,
right? That type of a thing. Yeah. Yeah.
This is So this is what I was trying to
get. I was trying to get somebody who
would sort of listen to this stuff and
sort of like get a picture of of really
what I'm trying to do here, right?
Cuz I was like looking on Upwork and
it's like are they actually going to
work? Like is somebody going to actually
work and like take the time to figure
out like the thing I'm trying to build,
right?
It's usually mixed. Like I've gotten
like really good stuff off of there, but
then I've also gotten just like crap off
of there.
I mean, I have some ideas, right? Like I
said, I It might be a cool thing. And I
could get you a clip of this, right? If
we think I like I should do
Maybe I should just get a clip of this
right now.
See if this works this time. There's
like a very slight variance to it.
So, let me put that in the drive view as
well.
I don't know if there's something where
it's like you can like just show this at
the start and like put it up in the
corner and then it comes back and by the
end it's trained. Um,
if you want other assets from me, like
let me know as well. If you like think
of like, oh, it would be cool if you had
something that did this or that.
That bot.
Oh.
Pretty well. It I know. I also have I
also have all sorts of graphs. I don't
know if any of these are useful.
Like this is a pretty crazy graph. It's
just a line. But the thing is this
X-axis, this is this is basically a
model that has played the g like this is
the MMO game, the one with like the
slashing and the bows and stuff pixel
art. So this thing has played this game
for like literally 10,000 years in this
graph. It's still running. Um it's going
to play the game for 20,000 years before
it's done fully. But like yeah, this
thing it literally like it's running
like simulation at 10,000 times plus
real time.
Oh, of course.
I'm going to go to bed in a in a few and
then probably check back in the morning
if that sounds good.
Quick question for you before you go,
Joseph, if that's all right. Um, so I'm
I've I've looked over the math. Um, I'm
almost sure it's not that. Um, besides
the observation size, is there anything
I should be uh double-checking to
um double checking that you're actually
like you're resetting the observations
correctly if they're like that they're
not they don't have stale data in them.
Terminals and rewards don't have stale
data in them. Um, let me see.
Those are usually the main culprits is
wrong rewards, wrong observations, wrong
resets. these types of things.
Got a
Oh, yeah. Viper, a few a few details
about the project and like the things I
work on. So, it's uh this details are at
puffer.ai.
Actually, let me DM this to you as well.
So,
project details
puffer.ai.
I can give you puffer logo
as well.
Uh, in fact, I can probably just get you
that.
I have the 3D model if you want that.
Um,
trying to think what what's the puffer
that I use on my
puffer
transparent gif. Uh, it's just the gif.
Okay, I'll give you I'll put the gif in
here then. should be high enough res to
like
it should be high enough res that like
when you put it small in the corner or
whatever or you put it somewhere he
should be fine.
Put this puffer in here.
There there's some details.
Uh
that's about it. All the other
information is on Puff AI and right on
our like the paragraph on our homepage.
Lots of stuff to pull from if you're
looking for ideas.
Okay, I'm going to go to sleep. Uh so
yeah, looking forward to seeing what you
hook up, Viper. And uh you can send me
like a low res preview or whatever you
want to do and I will uh and also
payment information.
Have a good night, Joseph. Thanks,
Matan.
Drop out a Discord. Yeah. And then uh
depending on uh what you come up with,
we'll figure out how much to tip you.
Looking forward to seeing it. Night
though, man. Bye.